finale aller de la coupe d'europe des
vainqueurs de coupes à domicile les
panthères créé la sensation victoire
23-22
on a travaillé pour essayer de faire un
espoir dans cette compétition on va
jamais arrivé dans une finale qu'on la
perd donc on les rats on a réussi à
sortir avec une victoire aujourd'hui
on voulait un petit truc à gérer on a un
but maintenant on a mis une pression
énorme sur une équipe qui va recevoir
donc voilà maintenant la pression est
sur les danoises et non d'aller là-bas
complètement libéré dernier celle fille
avant de quitter le loiret l'avion
décolle de la maison direction le
danemark
b
parce que la façon dont on a voyagé c1
c'est un très très gros avantage pour
plein de raisons d'abord sur la gestion
du temps de déplacement proprement dit
parce que ça nous a permis de partir à 8
heures pour arriver à 13h ont récupéré
nos chambres donc donc c'est quand même
exceptionnel ce que je pense qu'on a
gagné entre 4 et 5 heures par rapport à
un des placements classiques en fin de
saison tout compte
après on en est à 45 matchs pas dans le
coeur donc voilà ça commence à compter
c'est ce genre de petits détails
quelques heures gagnées pour une
préparation a fini on a réussi à faire
jeudi et vendredi des séances de qualité
donc moi j'ai pas de jets pas de besoin
pour me rassurer aujourd'hui elles m'ont
rassuré hier et jeudi
et voilà je sens qu'on équipe est prête
donc on va se détendre de se dégourdir
un peu les jambes et puis on verra ses
besoins de frapper tous s'imprégner des
lieux de l'ambiance de la ville entrer
progressivement dans le match il aura
lieu ici
li castres 22 arrêts la salle était non
cette semaine dimanche dimanche c'est
non mais c'est vrai que c'est de
l'impatience parce que voilà on aime
jouer ce match là c'est cela la deuxième
coupe d'europe après la championship
donc voilà franchement si on n'attend
pas ce match là avec impression ce jeu
parce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait là quoi
donc voilà
alors
pendant toute la semaine tu te fais le
film du match tu fais tu penses à ce que
tu as lutté pendant le match je pensais
et voilà on l'attend et quant à 68
peut-être d'un titre européen était
fausse et que ça arrive quoi et
heureusement que le match il à 15h10
parce que je pense que huit heures
j'aurai pas fait hier
ne passez pas à côté de ce moment qui va
vous faire grandir aller au bout de vos
intentions tactiques techniques dans le
défi physique pour celles qui sont
concernées par le défi physique mais
montrez vous aujourd'hui
ok on n'est pas là pour se cacher donc
on va vivre le match on va le vivre
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment travaillé
pour gagner oui est ce qu'on a créé les
conditions pour faire l'exploit oui
est-ce que vous avez toutes les
informations sur l'île de nantes
oui est-ce que vous avez été capable de
les battre oui est ce que vous êtes
capable de gagner à l'extérieur
oui ok vous êtes capables voilà
peut-être qu'elles vont nous battre
peut-être mais en tout cas une certitude
c'est qu'on est capable de le faire et
que si elles sont plus fortes que nous
parce qu'on est humble parce qu'on
accepte on leur serrera la main et on
partira la tête haute
mais avant ça il va falloir qu'elle nous
mettre par terre
ce combat elle ne livrerons pas seuls
supporters des panthères fidèles
il ne voulait pas rater ce grand rendez
vous c'est un événement exceptionnel que
pouvoir les jouer une finale de coupe
d'europe au danemark c'est assez
remarquable de pouvoir emmener une
quarantaine de deux personnes dans ces
conditions là puis on n'oublie pas non
plus les quelques supporters à 5,6
compris la route en minibus sawyer car
tout un mix de ce qui a fait notre
saison cette année en déplacement aussi
bien en france qu'en et en europe qui
est plutôt agréable à dîner on a fait
tous les déplacements à leone autriche
on allait aux pays-bas ou non cette
année on ait la chance de pouvoir
visiter pas mal de deux pays donc c'est
vrai que l'on se devait d'être présent
aujourd'hui quoi pour la finale et et
pour les voir on espère soulever le
trophée
oui
la partie a été dur trop dure 24 19
défaite logique est accepté on pensait
pas arriver là donc c'est que du bonus
ont été ça comme ça et à la finale du
championnat de france de karting
j'attends et voilà on va peut-être trop
fait
la fin d'une aventure mais pas du lot
ces zones
ito nasty